>> Sean: THIS IS HUGE.
MORE ON THIS LATER IN THE
SHOW.
YESTERDAY DURING A
CONFERENCE IN WASHINGTON
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR MAZIE
HIRONO EXPLAINING WHY
DEMOCRATS HAVE A HARD TIME
CONNECTING WITH VOTERS.
JUST TOO SMART.
GET TO THAT IN A MINUTE.
JOINING US FORMER SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE AUTHOR OF THE BEST
SELLER "TRUMP'S AMERICA."
NEWT GINGRICH.
WHEN YOU READ THIS THING ON
GENERAL FLYNN, WE FIND OUT,
OKAY, THAT THERE ARE ONLY
TWO KNOWN INSTANCES IN WHICH
INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN
INDICTED FOR VIOLATING THE
LOGAN ACT.
THE LAST OF WHICH CAME AT
1853.
AND NEITHER INDICTMENT
RESULT YOU HAD IN
CONVICTION.
AND THE OTHER ONE IS
MENTIONED IS THE FARRAH
MENTIONED IS THE FARAAH
MENTIONED IS THE FARA LAW
AND WE KNOW THAT THE DOJ
ISSUED A REPORT THAT TALLIED
ALL THE PROSECUTIONS UNDER
FARA SINCE 18966.
THAT WOULD BE SEVEN CASES
WITH ONE CONVICTION.
IS THIS HOW DEEP WE GO TO
GET A GUY THAT SERVED 33
YEARS IN THE MILITARY, THAT
THE FBI DIDN'T BELIEVE WAS
LYING?
>> SURE.
I MEAN, LOOK.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
MUELLER IS NOT INVOLVED IN A
INVESTIGATION.
MUELLER HAS A TRUMP
DESTRUCTION PROJECT.
HE BROUGHT ON A TEAM, ALL OF
THEM DEDICATED TO DESTROYING
TRUMP.
THEY HAVE DONE EVERYTHING
THEY COULD TO DESTROY TRUMP.
AND PART OF THAT TECHNIQUE,
WHICH, FRANKLY, SIDNEY
POWELL DESCRIBED BRILLIANTLY
IN HER BOOK, LICENSE TO LIE
ABOUT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
PART OF THAT TECHNIQUE IS
YOU THROW THE KITCHEN SINK.
YOU BASICALLY THREATEN
SOMEBODY AND SAY I'M GOING
TO BANKRUPT YOU, I'M GOING
TO PUT YOUR SON IN JAIL.
I AM GOING TO CHARGE WITH
YOU SO MANY DIFFERENT CRIMES
YOU WILL NEVER GET OUT FROM
UNDER IT.
NOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO TALK?
AND WHEN YOU HAVE THE FULL
POWER OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AGAINST YOU, IT'S
PRETTY TOUGH NOT TO TRY TO
FIND A WAY TO GET HIM OFF
YOUR BACK.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE TRUTH.
JUSTICE.
AND, MUELLER, I THINK, IN A
REALLY SAD -- HISTORIANS
SOME DAY WILL COMMENT THAT
THIS WAS ONE OF THE MOST
EXTRAORDINARY EFFORTS TO
UNDO THE WILL OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE BY AN
ESTABLISHED BUREAUCRACY AND
ITS ESTABLISHMENT FRIENDS
THAT WE HAVE SEEN IN ALL OF
MARKET RESEARCH
AMRKET RESEARCH
AMERET RESEARCH
AMERIC RESEARCH
AMERICANESEARCH
AMERICAN HEARCH
AMERICAN HISRCH
AMERICAN HISTOH
AMERICAN HISTORY.
I WANT TO MAKE ONE POINT
JUST TO PUT THIS IN CONTEXT.
DONALD TRUMP AFTER 92%
NEGATIVE COVERAGE FOR TWO
YEARS, 92% NEGATIVE COVERAGE
FOR TWO YEARS IS SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN 44 AND 48% APPROVAL,
DEPENDING ON THE POLL.
RONALD REAGAN ABOUT THIS
POINT IN 1983 WAS AT 35%.
THE FACT IS THAT MCCRONE, MACRON
WONDER BOY OF FRANCE 25,
26%.
JUST HAD THE WORST RIOTS IN
PARIS IN 50 YEARS.
SO, THE WHOLE NOTION THAT
MUELLER IS NOW THE PERSON
WHO IS GOING TO GO OUT AND
SAVE AMERICA BY DESTROYING
THE PRESIDENT, I THINK IS AN
ANTI CONSTITUTIONAL EFFORT
BY THE ORGANIZED LEFT.
>> Sean: JOHN SOLOMON JUST
BREAKS THIS SORRY.
WE KNEW THEY DIDN'T VERIFY
THE DOSSIER AND IT WAS NOT
CORROBORATED, WHICH IS PART
OF THEIR PROTOCOL AND ALSO
PART OF THE LAW.
BUT NOW WE SEE AN EMAIL
CHAIN WHERE THEY KNEW IT HAD
MASSIVE CREDIBILITY
PROBLEMS.
THIS IS WHAT HE DISCOVERED
EMAIL CHANGE WITH ALL THESE
PEOPLE NAMES IN IT THAT
SHOWS THEY KNEW THERE WAS
PROBLEM TO THE VERY BULK OF
EVIDENCE THAT WAS USED TO
OBTAIN THE FISA WARRANTS IN
THE FISA APPLICATION AND
THEY WITHHELD ALL OF THAT
EXCULPATORY INFORMATION FROM
THE JUDGES AND AS WELL AS
WHO PAID FOR IT WHICH WAS
HILLARY AND IT WAS A
POLITICAL DOCUMENT.
HOW CAN THEY GET AWAY WITH
THAT ABUSE OF POWER?
>> WELL, BECAUSE THEY'RE THE
ESTABLISHMENT.
THEY ARE THE FIX.
THEY ARE THE INSIDERS.
THEY ARE THE GUYS THOUGHT
"NEW YORK TIMES" AND OUT
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AND
ALL THE NETWORKS EXCEPT FOR
FOX ALL SURROUND AND PROTECT
THEM.
THEY OPERATED ON A PREMISE
OF COURSE THEY ALL THOUGHT
HILLARY WAS GOING TO WIN.
THEY NEVER THOUGHT THIS WAS
GOING TO COME TO LIGHT.
THEY THOUGHT THEY WERE
HELPING THE WINNER.
IT WAS ENORMOUS SHOCK
ELECTION NIGHT TO STARTED
COMEY IN PARTICULAR TO
SUDDENLY START REALIZING
THAT HIS NECK WAS ON THE
LINE.
HE HAD BEEN BREAKING THE
LAW.
HE ALWAYS THOUGHT HE WOULD
BE PROTECTED.
EVERYBODY NEAR THE CLINTONS
HAVE BEEN PROTECTED AS YOU
POINTED OUT.
>> Sean: COMEY'S NAME IS ON
THIS EMAIL CHAIN.
HE WAS ON THE EMAIL CHAIN.
HE SIGNED OFF ON THAT.
>> OF COURSE.
YOU HAD THE DIRECTOR OF THE
FEDERAL BUREAU OF
INVESTIGATION ACTIVELY
TRYING TO DESTROY A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE.
YOU HAVE THE FORMER HEAD OF
THE FBI, BOB MUELLER,
ACTIVELY TRYING TO DESTROY
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
AND I KNOW IT'S FRUSTRATING
BUT THE FACT IS, THIS IS A
CLEAR CUT DRAMA.
THEY HATE HIM.
THEY WANT TO DESTROY HIM IT
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
TRUTH AND NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE LAW.
>> Sean: IF WE DON'T GET
EVERYONE ELSE THAT LIES THAT
WE KNOW LIES UNDER OATH IF
HILLARY IS NEVER HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
YOU CAN SAY WE HAVE NO EQUAL